a horse does not finish maturing and
their their ligaments and tendons and
their their their bone structure does
not finish growing until the age of
seven right so for our two and
three-year-olds to be racing in that
magnitude and that amount of stress on
their bodies it really just it's not a
good thing and do they race you at that
age I didn't know that that's the age
the Kentucky Derby are three-year-olds
I was over I was living in a world where
they were happy living and racing in the
woods and we were just making their life
better and taking knots out of their
hair well now I hear that with slave
laboring child labor horses running down
those children horses should be off
building iPads like real child they
shouldn't be made to raise for our
entertainment make me a shoe horse